and it's we got a really good one today
so we got none of the three-part series
so this will be part 1 on the modern
Benoni there were one or two people that
had been requesting this and I think
it's it's a great idea it's a very sharp
very crazy and very theoretical opening
so I don't mind going over it in three
parts it seems to makes a lot of sense
and Darian here who's in the audience he
comes he comes to all my lectures he's
the only guy he said you know it's an e
for heavy class we need to get some D
for openings going and I tend to agree
with that so we're going to be doing a
lot more D for openings and we're
starting with this three-part series on
the modern benoni
so with that in mind we'll jump over to
the board now and after the moves d4
Knight f6 Knight c4 black now has to
figure out what he's going to do about
how he's going to challenge the center
so obviously II 6 + G 6 are very popular
moves but tonight we're going to look at
the very aggressive c5 which immediately
strikes at the center when will he be
focused on the main line which is
pushing here ok 9 f3 also is interesting
and I do hope we can go over that
somedays because there's some
interesting positions that can arise
that are unique to that position
but we're going to be focused on the
move d5 and the most popular move here
is actually b5 because in this position
what White's next couple moves are if we
just give him some moves is he's going
to put his knight on c3 and play e4 so
you need to come up with some way of
challenging the center before he just
gets to go through with his ideas which
is why the Bangko gambit is one of the
most popular openings we talked about
the fianchetto variation but there's
some other variations I I would like to
cover in the future but we're going to
be looking at ISA 'kx the modern benoni
and the idea is to be able to take on d5
before white has time to cement to
center with the movie for it and this
will lead to an imbalanced pawn
structure in a very interesting struggle
you'll notice white has extra
face so that's a big Trump that he has
and okay we'll just go a couple more
moves because almost all games followed
the same path now you take on d5 before
he has time to play you for and after
the recapture d6 and this is the basic
pawn skeleton that we'll be looking at
for the next few days and what actually
has several plans here but first let's
talk about what it is that black wants
to do black has a lot more space on the
queenside so that's where he'll be
focusing all of his attention so you
know given the chance he's going to play
the moves a 6 B 5 and get a lot of space
on the queenside
and often the move c4 which allows one
of the Knights to Rhema new ver to c5 so
in lines where white just does nothing
to oppose blacks plan that's what black
is going to be doing also when this pond
went to d5 you'll notice that this
diagonal was weakened so this Bishop is
almost always going to be fianchettoed
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense on
e7 but okay this diagonal you can see it
has a lot of possibilities so his plans
are g6 Bishop g7 and most likely he's
going to castle on that side now white
who has more space in the center is
going to be playing on the other side of
the board he's going to be trying to
play moves like efore f4 and eventually
e5 and if he gets a 5 in successfully
then he's he's playing the game very
well and games that end really quick
there's games in the database that are
less than 20 moves usually that means
white just play d5 and the game ended
immediately so black does have to really
be be careful you are living on the edge
which is why some people are a bit
suspicious of this opening in okay
there's there's main ways today we're
actually going to be looking at one of
the most critical though not most
popular variations which will be the
time on of attack which so we're just
going to look what happens if white just
goes for it and tries to kill black
right out of the gate that'll be the
main focus of today and lesson 2 we'll
go over lines where they play the put
the pawn on e4 and they play Knight to
f3 you know with or without h3 and
Bishop d3 these sorts of moves that'll
be in lesson two and in the final
lecture we'll be going over the
fianchetto variation where white doesn't
even touch the e pawn until later he
mostly tries to restrict all of blacks
options and only then does he when he
when he's all his pieces ready to go and
then in the distant future he'll play e4
and f4 and the same sorts of things but
let's just let's just be serious on day
one okay e4 and after g6 we're going to
fianchetto the bishop
let's just play f4 and you know this
already might be something that you
might be be kind of intimidated as black
maybe you don't think you want to play
this so the main move here is actually
just Bishop g7 and you're telling what
you're not threatening e5 and once you
look at a few moves here so if we get a
good look at this position this is our
basic starting position we'll show three
different moves and yeah that's actually
it's interesting so what happens if he
just plays the move e5 and this is the
McInnis attack so it's a you know very
difficult if it's your first time you
know you might be a little scared some
some audience members are apparently not
scared some people are just laughing at
you five you can't do that
black actually has two moves and they
both should at least equalize so this
isn't a very scary threat and the moves
are taking on e5 and moving the knight
gets attacked to d7 the most popular is
just to move the knight and that would
be my recommendation I think that's just
the best move but let's just have a look
real quick at what happens if we take
with the pond okay they should obviously
take back the night is still attacked
and after we retreat we're attacking a
five twice you could defend it once but
that's not going to save you so white
already has to sort of mix it up and
make the game a little chaotic with the
movie six okay could be could be scary
if this is your first time seeing this
but let's get that off the bloop window
here you can just take and it's always
worth noting whether or not this trick
with Queen two
four works here it doesn't on the point
is you're provoking g3 and now you you
want to play Queen to e4 but obviously
the knight will take you so you can
exchange the Knights will check and play
Queen e4 and then you can hope do you
pick up the rook but if what is careful
what is what should white just play here
oh yeah Queen e2 and yeah so if you take
this rook not only does it look really
bad that he's taking on d7 but it's
actually mate in ten so here you'd have
to trade the Queen's and then this you
know excursion didn't really make a
whole lot of sense so okay so going back
here we take they take back all right
smart Bensimon 20 found a bunch of
people all right good job done Simon and
in this position the most common move is
Queen to e7 though Knight f6 and you
trade Queens is also an interesting and
game for black it should be roughly
level but after here this move and you
can reach this endgame so this is very
typical and you could play Bishop to e5
and defend the c7 square and you can
play a little bit more viciously too by
sacrificing an exchange so this also is
a possible way to play and it's not
really so important to go into the
theory of this line as much but just to
give you a general idea for the overall
feel feel of the Benoni
all the time you're going to be
sacrificing exchanges and material and
going for dynamic elements rather than
just you know static long-term
advantages so we'll return and we'll go
ahead for those are just joining us this
is the modern benoni and we're looking
at the real aggressive lines with E 4
and F 4 all right and one more time
we'll run through the McKenna's attack
but with a different variation we'll
look one more time at night f2 d7 okay
you simply just move the piece that was
attacked makes them okay
just sort of a shocking move it's the
same if you go to e4 Knight to b5 is a
little bit more popular so okay either
way it leads to a very interesting pawn
sacrifice in this variation the point is
we take and now Knight d6 and you have
two choices with your King and if you're
playing the Benoni you want to be as
active as possible and you got to be
fearless King e7 and you're not joking
you're going to take the knight if
Knight f3 you take on d6
and it's not bughouse so black will
survive you're not meeting me in
bughouse
you know blacks misplayed this position
but okay so yeah 96 King g7 and now you
take the bishop because the threat of
taking the knight was real okay
and now you should just prioritize
getting developed and we get such a
position we can take back and now an
interesting move what kind of wants to
castle so we can play a forceful Bishop
move Bishop to b5 and after we block
castles and King escapes and you're a
pawn up so it's very interesting takes
takes white is trying to get as active
as possible okay say we play here and
these are the types of moves that you
want to find you know finding ways to
sacrifice the exchange the big point
here is that we have this check which
picks up the bishop so what can even go
for an endgame here you can play Queen
to d4 and after any rook move wouldn't
go into this end game which okay should
be roughly equal we can take this pawn
and notice too if you play rook b1 do we
have this this nice escape Queen to d4
and the bishop going to d4 with check is
actually a big theme in this opening in
general so often you know you need to
make use of this in this case to save
upon but if we just look at at this
position for
and we can see that black is a pawn up
however white has the two bishops and
the board is wide open so he should have
you know a lot of compensation and the
deep on is is quite nice to have it's a
pretty strong pawn but overall this
should just be sort of an equal game if
you do end up playing this way and okay
I don't I don't really know who I even
prefer I would play either side of this
I think it's it's just fine does the
audience have any preference just out of
curiosity yeah black has activity yeah
both sides are sort of active blacks
upon up and okay I mean it's you kind of
like black okay alright yeah it's
interesting
so this is at one variation they you
know you might want to play but it's not
a very common one so we'll go back and
we'll get to our are more popular moves
here okay after Bishop g7 the next most
logical move that you would probably
consider in this position is just the
simple move I mean Knight to f3 that's
that's as logical as it gets right you
develop your Kings side a knight however
this doesn't cause black any problems
immediately so there's actually a more
forceful move that white can play that
will look at last so here you just
Castle and white has an interesting
decision he's he's obviously needing to
move this bishop next and okay I guess
the computer wants you to go to e2 so
we'll look at that first and this is
actually transposed into the four pawns
attack of the Kings Indian so another
way to reach this position let's just
back up and for for argument's sake here
let's see if it'll let me do this so
okay there's this very aggressive line
in the Kings Indian where you can play
in a c5 okay and then in this position
they play here and you take here and
then this is the same exact position
okay so we'll go back well we'll do it
via the the Benoni move order
okay so we'll play Knight f3 here and so
if Bishop to e2 this is obviously a
different opening now but it's not going
to stop us from just showing one of the
fun lines so rook e8 the whole thing is
based off of white trying to play e5 in
black constantly stopping him from doing
it
so the rook comes to e8 very sensible
you know you're attacking the pawn but
now white can try to move e5 I mean
because what else you're not going to
play Bishop d3 after you played Bishop
d2 to protect the pawn so here he pushes
immediately and we can take and so we
got to move our Knight so we'll go to
the most active square we possibly can
Knight to g4 okay so we're attacking
that pond several times so you can throw
this move in and so this is all Kings
Indian Theory mr. a Queen b6 and white
can usually defend his pawn if he wants
or you can dare black to take it but the
lines where you dare black to take on b2
first let's just take on e5 for a second
and let's play Bishop to c4 I dare you
to take on b2 I want to show this line
just out of interest ache actually the
next 10 to 20 moves are all like
computers like it's forced there's only
one move so we'll we'll watch this
mostly just for enjoyment here but you
dare me okay I take it and now d6
so just ignoring that the night is
hanging and threatening f7 which is
serious business if you just take this
night for example we're going to take
here and then you know all sorts of bad
stuff is going to happen you know we're
just going to get the rook unless you
want to welcome to the F file which has
its own own scary dangers so I mean the
threat of taking on f7 is very serious
so we'll we'll just protect it and now
again a very nice move here Bishop takes
f7 and okay it's like what's what's this
well if you take the bishop then Queen
d5 is good for white which is which is
sort of frustrating so you don't want to
take the bishop you just move
and the bishop just goes back to d5 and
now the threat is actually rook takes m8
if this rook takes here and the King has
to take back and go on the F file the
Queen is swinging into the attack the
bishop can go to h6 this Bishop is
awesome so really bad stuff are going to
happen if you don't respond to this
threat if you take the knight you're
actually losing so you defend the rook I
want to be able to take back with a
piece I don't want you Bishop to be able
to go to h6 I don't want your Queen to
go to f1 with Czech and now they take ok
you take back this way and okay
and everybody's confused it's very
confusing okay well fine I'll take that
for this check so now the night on that
fate is hanging the queens are attacking
each other let's trade those guys let's
throw this guy in check and hear and you
reach this crazy position all crazy and
black has emerged upon up but this
virtually forced line so the computer
says ok black is plus one here you know
black he's up upon and yeah all of that
is like completely forced so if you want
to learn all this long complicated
theoretical lines they're all they're
very interesting I show it mostly for
amusement I think it's just some
fantastic stuff but it was straights
the key point in all of the Benoni which
is you know more more important than
actually winning material and everything
is having dynamic active pieces and
playing for the initiative it matters a
whole lot more than actually winning
material whether it's a pawn in exchange
I mean whatever you just you need to
have your pieces in the optimal squares
ok and we'll show one more line here too
in the Knight f3 variation let's say we
play here which seems like sort of an
improvement over the the other line
because ok that's a more natural square
for the Bishop white we'll probably want
to put a rook on the e-file so that he's
threatening to e5 push at some point so
black plays here immediately
and white castle's
and we won't go too much into this but
this also is a common theme that's worth
worth noting you did something kind of
similar to this when you're playing
Danny so the point is if you take here
you're removing a defender of efore and
E for being more important than the C
pawn white will retreat and another
typical theme along the very same line
b5 okay with the same idea since now I'm
trying to hang this pawn so that I can
take on you four and play may continue
like this and then the Black Knight goes
to c5 so you get a very interesting
typical position and so what black is
able to get the Queen side pawns to
where he wants this is the typical
structure that you're going to achieve
with your pawns here on the light
squares so then I can go to c5 yeah c5
and then okay at some top points you can
jump in here also he has some pressure
on the center when he gets to c5 so you
reach sort of a typical structure that
that blacks should be happy with but
obviously I can play this way there's
there's nothing wrong with playing this
way as white as well but just wanted to
point that out and now we'll be really
serious here we'll go over the main
stuff so we return to this position and
black is about to Castle what does the
move white can play to interrupt his
plan yeah fish would be five check
so okay you can't castle on this turn
unless you're playing in the kids
tournaments when you playing the kids
tournaments they like Castle here right
castling is a good move right no and
then you touched your king and then they
make you move your king and you're sad
okay so how should you block and it's
also very interesting because every move
here might surprise you which is why it
really pays to be well booked up when
you play this line the main move is
Knight F to d7 and to understand that
let's try to play what seems like the
most natural move which is not be at V 7
I mean that certainly you know feels
most natural that's where the Knights
going to go anyway he's controlling e5
next week
[ __ ] everything's great and this
actually is played on occasion by people
that are well prepared you know top
grandmasters and stuff that uh the ones
that play the benoni they sometimes do
this probably mostly as a surprise
weapon but some people have tried to
revive it so if you end up playing this
way it's not like you've you've
completely blown anything but here we
get some fun after the movie five okay
and in general we should just take this
now we've got to move our night our
squares are pretty pretty limited so
we'll go to H five and we have ideas of
Queen to h4 and one can play e6 and not
worry about your threats you say he's
got threats of his own he's on d7 the
knight is pinned it's not going anywhere
but black goes on in Queen Dage four
okay and now this moved g3 and the
typical trick is taking on g3 and this
is actually fine for what I mean what
should be happy with this variation he
takes the knight giving up the rook so
that's how he solves that problem
and now just a simple move the knight is
attacked protect the night and the night
on d7 isn't going anywhere so you'll be
able to take that next and now again a
shocker if you haven't played this a lot
you know you might just be thinking I
don't know what you
what would you guys do here I guess you
probably can castle or take on these six
or queen g2 queen g2 seems to make make
a lot of sense but what is actually
making sort of a lot of threats here
with with taking twice you know getting
this Queen and involved and castling
this way so you actually need to be
ready to expose the White King over
there in a lot of lines so the shocking
move is Bishop takes c3 getting rid of
an important attacker sometimes that
Knight actually can jump into certain
squares you know your king is about to
be misplaced so it does make sense to
eliminate some of the pieces and you
know the white King won't find perfect
shelter on any side of the board now and
again you you know you want to castle
and everything but then he just takes
what the pawn on d7 so this position
black usually forces the issue okay you
take me and so we take a whole bunch of
times and now there's a lot of moves
here so I can try several things you
know the Queen should can go here the
Queen can go here the Queen can go here
I think the best way for white to follow
up in this position is to go to all of
those squares okay Queen to a4 and you
provoke weaknesses swing over to g4
provoke some more weaknesses and Queen
to f3
so trying out all of the squares alright
hey Arjun is that for me sure yeah sure
all right thank you Arjun you're the
best all right got the kit kats got the
kid kids okay so we trade Queens here
and now another interesting endgame
black is up to pawns White has two
pieces for a rook and this actually
should be pleasant for white there are
quite a lot of weaknesses in the in
Black's camp and having the extra piece
material you have two pieces for the
rook is more important than actually
having the two pawns at least in
practice and according to the computer
your games may vary
so this is why this this isn't as
popular so this is supposed to be good
for white so we return now do you know
the name of this opening because I
already forgot yeah okay
ee you read oh you were able to read it
away up i alright but the audience at
home can't see that so they didn't know
which is why in this position the most
popular move now we can sort of start to
appreciate it
Knight F to d7 and so this Knight is you
know you know you might be worried about
some of your pieces here okay he's not
going here he's not going here
some of us likely he's actually going to
end up going to a6 this is what we're
going to find out white wants to develop
and castle but the move a4 and we'll
look at the move Knight to f3 before the
start of our first game here tonight and
only game a for what's the point of that
move what could that be about can anyone
explain that move to me yes
yeah exactly excellent Arjun yeah you're
stopping the pond storm here which is
what black intended to play so if in
lines with Knight to f3 we'll have a
look at what happens when black plays a
six but let's just take a real quick
look here at the main main line here now
we can castle which is the main move and
the move I would recommend though there
is something to be said about the other
variation which is Queen to h4 which has
been played by some you know good
grandmasters including Gelfand and in
this position the most common retreat is
actually to e7 but all of the higher
rated grandmasters have tried this move
Queen to d8 so okay we don't have time
for both we'll just take a quick look
and we'll just show the game between
beret off and gelfand from Canty man
sees 2005 okay so in this game they
develop the castle and there is
something to be said about the move
Knight to a6 which is a very popular
move in this position but Gelfand
preferred this move a6 and after Bishop
to c4 the knight goes to b6 okay so
you're in the way of the B pond but
you're forcing the bishop away and it
should be mentioned that there always is
the question of where this bishop should
go it's actually a huge question in
these lines and usually there's more
than one you know right answer or move
that can be played even the capture
often makes a lot of sense because the
knight is actually quite good for black
it's preventing e5 it might go to f6
later and attack the center so this move
actually is playable when you put your
bishop on c4 you're often saying I'm
supporting the D pawn so I don't have to
worry about if you you know you're on my
D pawn a bunch of times and I can play
the movie five so you know this move is
very good for protecting the center this
obviously is a very natural diagonal it
seems like okay maybe that just seems
like a nice normal Square for a bishop
obviously that's that's good when you've
already castle Bishop to e2 makes a
little bit less
just because normally in the other line
when we stop Bishop to e2 it was to
shield the e-file so you could play an
immediate d5 without stuff happening on
the e-file but the other moves have all
been played and makes sense you can take
the knight you can go back to C forward
and go back to d3
alright brave went to c4 and now after
the bishop was kicked away and again it
could go to d3 as well as that's fine a
nice little move here Bishop to g4 which
is often a part of Black's plan he does
want to trade the bishop for the night
the knight actually has a very nice
route that we'll see in a lot more
openings you know other than when the e4
f4 openings it doesn't happen as much
but there's a very common maneuver or
the night maneuvers over to c4 and if
it's safe there it has a lot of pressure
on the D pawn so here actually in the
following position he should have played
a move like Knight to d2 just preserving
the knight but instead he played Queen
to c2 which is actually a mistake and
now after a few more moves okay he
didn't have to push but we're getting
ready to take the knight on c3 and then
gobble up the center pawn so he decided
to push and after the trades here he
takes and as always you can take the
pawn on e5 so Bishop takes d5 is a
perfectly good move but it's a benoni so
you never take anything that's that's
how the opening works you never you
never take the stuff so he decides to
get all these pieces out and he gets
attacked and now here again you know you
can take with the Bishop this is a good
bow for me there's nothing wrong with it
but he prefers to like give up some
material so he traits the pawns instead
of just winning anything and he goes
back and in this position he's won in
exchange we protect upon and we'll just
stop right here and black has achieved a
very nice position he's won a little bit
of material and you had a question you
age in your head okay
so this actually was good for black then
the game got really really complicated
because that's how the benoni works and
then it was a draw
so we won't we will show you the rest
we'll show you this nice position and
there yeah that's all you need to see
okay but with that in mind to will we'll
jump back to the main game this let's
just have one more look here okay so
that's that's a possible move here in
this this move order here a very popular
line let's take a little look here
though at the main main main line we're
getting really close to the starting
point for most of theory and okay after
night of three White's going to castle
the knight goes to a six this is the
main point and from there he can go to
two different squares so both of these
are ideas in the position they both make
a lot of sense so after castling in our
main game we're going to look up to move
Knight to b4 which i think is just the
best move it seems to be what the top
grandmasters like to play in this
position though it's not as popular as
this move though it is gaining in
popularity especially recently but we'll
look real quick here
I mean Knight to c7 that also makes a
lot of sense you attack the bishop on b5
you have some pressure in the center and
okay yes well we'll look at that when we
get to the actual game I guess that's
where it is yeah it is a hyper modern
opening you're yep white you can have
the whole center sure that's that's
fully yours and I'm going to go for some
you know active play I'm going to try to
get very active pieces get some counter
play you know generate some some crazy
nonsense and mix up the board and mess
everything up and make it really
confusing and then dandy Machuca head
explodes because it's just too
complicated right Danny
alright welcome to the class as a book
house over are they still plan mario
bailed so now you got now okay so now
people can start coming back to my
lecture that's good and yeah that's also
why it's an ideal weapon especially if
you play a lot of lower rated opponents
because you get sharp wild positions and
I mean both sides are playing for
win and okay I play a lot of lower rated
opponents because I teach here so it's a
very good opening for me to use so I've
been employing it recently and with
great success because it gets so
complicated and then the better
technician wins so I mean it's it's for
that reason you imbalance the game right
from the start and you get some some
really wild positions and okay you got
to have some fun in chess so it is it is
always fun to play and with that in mind
we'll jump to our first and only
entertaining game and this is a game
between beriev and T'Pol off from the
candidates match in 2002 okay very
important game and we reach it via a
slightly different move order and this
also is a common move order that people
like to employ when they use this
opening they start okay maybe I'm going
to go for the nihms Oh
and regardless of whatever you know
white picks of all of these the three
most common moves black can play the
same way you play c5 okay I'm going to
play the nihms oh just kidding so we get
the Benoni because now after d5 we take
and we reach to this familiar position
okay we need to if you know our bishop
he's going to come get us
I'm about to castle he throws the
check-in to disturb me I moved this
Knight back and the main move of course
is a four but okay it's it is worth
noting what happens if they don't play a
four this is a lot less popular because
black does just get to do what his
general plan is so here he kicks the
bishop back and he plays the move b5 and
we'll just go a little bit farther you
just get this this typical move see I
did write a note to myself okay and you
just get sort of a typical position
whereby kotzen what he wants to do and
like it's to do what he wants to do so
unfortunately we won't get to look at
these positions today it's mostly gonna
be like in lesson two we'll see sort of
positions that are a little bit closer
to to this but that is possible so if
they don't prevent you then you just do
what you want to do alright so a four
and we Castle they get ready and we put
our knight on a six-day castle and in
the game night to be four was played but
we'll have a look at night to see seven
yeah personally I don't I don't really
like blacks chances of getting fighting
for the wind in this position will just
show so basically he's going to play for
b5 and white is just going to go ahead
and play for a five which tends to
happen there's also one Bishop maneuver
that's also worth noting like what is
what is y going to do with this piece
very often he's going to F 2 n over 2 H
4 which can sometimes harass the black
queen which can lead to some some issues
for black for example as in this game
you get to do what you want to do and
white does what he wants to do and okay
personally this seems a little
inconvenient as black especially because
you play c4 they get to play this move
and this should be quite good for white
for example the human move that has been
played before is f6 you shocked you want
to play that you would you'd play more
like the computer this other computer
wants to play but this this also is not
very impressive
so obviously the computer doesn't take
the stuff because it's a Bonomi yeah you
want to just put your knight here and
this is good for white and it doesn't
inspire a lot of confidence when you
have to get rid of your dark squared
Bishop for no clear reason but okay this
this also can lead to some issues based
on the fact that they can like take here
your pawn doesn't belong on f6 the
Knights still comes to c6 in these
positions maybe tenable but I'd strongly
recommend Knight to be four and these
these positions
in the nights good on before I get to
stay there for a very long time I'm
attacking d5 okay it's just a just a
good move and now here the most popular
move was not played in the game h3 which
is a very useful move in the future I'm
not gonna be able to play Bishop to g4
but we'll look at the the main main line
here which is rook to e1 I mean
everything has to do with E 5 so this
makes a lot of sense now a6 and this is
sort of the point you know you get to
retreat all the way back to f1 and in
the future sometimes like both these
this happens and then this happens and
this happens so I saw one game where
that happened and then white one pretty
easily so that is one of the the plans
that he has and rook to e8 okay just
it's all about controlling e5 and now H
6 plus is the main mainline nothing not
the game and the actual the most popular
move here is b6 though I would like to
go back to this position so remember it
will go over a more dynamic way to play
because now after here okay he's doing
his plan the Bishop's going over to F
for most people play this way which is
fine but I don't ever really see black
doing more than just holding the
position it gets to a point where it is
hard for black to make significant
progress so I mean when they when they
play Queen to h4 a bishop to h4 you can
play Queen to c7 but it feels like black
is just trying to hold everything
together which is why I would prefer in
this position a move like f5 you know
real aggressive stuff let's let's get
let's get serious here and if you play
e5 we take several times the main move
is actually Queen to b3 and okay we do
some some trading we're going to run a
little bit low on time so we'll just
show some position like this okay and I
do want to just point out one mistake to
taking here is is unfortunate because
do you take this rook if you take with
the Queen the knight goes to c2 which is
very good and if you take with a knight
then you took with your night the knight
doesn't belong there and okay blacks
King is obviously a little bit loose but
this is quite typical in this opening
and the Knights going to go to f6
potentially to e4 and you're just going
to try to put your pieces on very active
squares so this is a typical position
that blacks should be comfortable with
if you're you're playing this this
opening but let's let's get to the game
okay so this was the game in after night
before the move h3 okay okay okay all
right
Bishop to c4 we've seen that that's a
very common square especially I mean it
doesn't make sense if I can play b5 with
your account and are just offending the
D pawn and you're you're hoping at some
point I play Knight to b6 to block my
own pawns and I like this plan f5 I
think this is the typical way that
blacks should try to break out in this
this type of position it's very sharp
and complicated there's so many things
that can happen now in the center in the
game he played a very logical move
Knight to g5 he's just coming into e6
okay that's very very sensible we will
look at this line very briefly this is
actually a mistake and the reason is
after Knight to b6
we've pre moved Bishop to f5 no matter
what you do that's that's what we're
doing and okay and it's all about
activity so here black just gets active
no matter what
also reasonable and perfectly fine is is
pushing if you get another chance you'll
probably push to e6 this also would have
been a reasonable way to play but now we
can take in d6 check and this also would
have been an interesting line because
after here now if you jump into g5 and
you're threatening to win in exchange in
two different ways
that can actually play the movie for
because again we don't care about the
material you can have the exchange and I
can even go into this end game and my
pieces are just going to be more active
I have a pawn for the rook my e4 pawn is
looking pretty good
my next couple of moves are Bishop d6
and rook to d8 and I pick up another
pawn so this actually would be quite
good for black so it's easy to see why
he avoided these lines and instead in
this position lift upon untouched on the
e4 and play Knight to g5 okay given the
chance I'm going to go to e6
so now he went to b6 with the night
makes sense if you put your night on
these six I can take it with my bishop
now I'm attacking your bishop
so he went back then you wanted to stay
connected to the center and now black
made a move that might also surprise the
audience because that's other Benoni
works every move is a surprise at some
point I'm going to want to play the move
c4 you know and then kick that [ __ ] up
around and when I do that I probably
want this guy to be defended so in this
position
a5 this is not chess all right it's been
claimed that this is not chess okay
because you see your positionally you're
giving away b5 but okay what are you
really going to do on b5 if you're just
going to just keep tickling my deep on
just all day long
we're not to worry about it because
we're playing c4 and then if we if we
play this move you know we get some
nights might be able to jump in so even
though the audience is not impressed
this was the super grandmaster move and
computer recommended so we move on all
right we know sort of the typical bishop
maneuver in lblack took so he's up upon
and you might be thinking first of all
in the game king h1 which which isn't a
very good move was played instead Queen
d2 would have just been fine it's just
some normal move like this but okay what
happens if we take this well there's
there's a lot of things that are going
on here among them this pawn is not
protected so this actually would be
quite good for black which is why it's
okay it's obvious that you don't want to
take the pawn back we'll just leave it
there that's that's fine our pieces are
pretty active here as white but in the
game King h1 which is just a little bit
slow because now this is sort of a
dynamic move that you you play when you
play the Benoni
Knight to d3 and it may look a little
careless at first because okay at some
point he's going to take our EEP on one
of these Knights is going to take this
and then is our Knight just going to be
marooned in White's territory and lost
forever or will you be able to do stuff
while you have the moments are you
making enough threats well we're like
attacking stuff you know sometimes
attacking this thing but we're really
attacking this thing and so okay yeah
it's just a very dynamic move you got
that really active
I can never tell if you're if you're
just scratching your head or raising
your hand do you just you just crach
your head the whole time is that what
you're scratching it
yeah and it's a confusing opening it's
like oh so confusing oh is that your
heads edgy is it the position that makes
you itchy
maybe all right and you may be able to
consider taking here this this might be
possible but okay I mean sticking with
the theme of never taking the stuff he
protects his be upon and I'm thinking
about taking the e-pawn on my next turn
all right
but now Ricky eight yeah Ricky eight is
a little bit of a mistake but white
returns the favor with the move rook a
that'd be one which seems just like a
normal move the actual the way to
exploit this last move by black is using
our crazy supercomputer line that no
human would ever find not even Danny
Machuca in the back he looks but mused
so here the computer wants you to play
the move Knight C takes e4 and yeah
everybody's confused okay you can take
here just grab the pawn sure in the move
that white should make here is rook a to
c1 so you're defending against the
knight coming back and you don't care
about this guy okay you can take there
you want the pawn you can take there
because it's all about activity it's it
does that's like useless so the computer
instead wants to play this very
entertaining line yeah sure just just
exchange that night all right good get
your active pieces and now this actually
is a typical sacrifice here it's quite
dramatic it's quite a dramatic example
but there is sort of a typical sacrifice
we do still want to play d6
so you sack the night
and then you take care and the reason
you can play here instead of just having
to play d6 immediately is also fantastic
it's because after Queens a d6
blockading rook c6 and after it takes it
looks sort of like okay black you just
made a huge blunder you're in check I'm
attacking your queen but we can play
here and yeah computers like you know
Lex better so you had to see all that to
really punish White's play and okay I
mean that's it's fantastic stuff but
it's it's not very human so it when we
return to this position after Queen d2
he played rook e8 which is okay I mean
it's about it's about balanced here okay
so he played here in black played Bishop
to f5 so he defended his epon of course
g4 was sort of encouraged and you don't
really want to move your bishop because
then he is actually taking the e pawn so
h6 yeah and there's nothing better than
trading
all right and he took here and now white
made a big mistake yeah he took yeah
yeah yeah he took much better
what's Queenie to with the idea of
coming over to the the King side here
but he took and okay it doesn't it's not
immediately obvious how this is some big
mistake and I think we have a little bit
of time so I'll give the audience a
chance to to do a little planning here
how would you guys punish this move it's
it's not incredibly easy but this
actually is a mistake we'll see if we
see if we can figure it out
Queen d7 yeah and he protected it yeah
you never you never thought I'd protect
it
who said it yeah rookie five so this
this was played so the point is I'm
threatening to just win your rope so he
went to f7 and of course black played
Queen takes pawn
yeah Queen h3 and okay you have to you
have to block otherwise I take on g5
we'll check don't don't play King g1 and
they got this positioned and what's
funny is now the computer is like yeah
go ahead take this pond just allow white
to take here and double and do all sorts
of crazy stuff you can only take stuff
when like everything's complicated and
they get lots of counter play that's
when the computer wants to take stuff
okay put a very humid decision rook to
f8 and okay so we got this trade and
black has five pawns White has four and
black has you know the more active
pieces this guy is kind of shut out of
the game and we'll see and now there's
their sort of a lot of maneuvering so
we'll go through this you again you can
take on b2 but that's not how this
opening works and he knows it when you
can take on b6 and I take on v3 and but
okay white doesn't really want to trade
here again you could you can take on d5
and I takes d5 which is okay but Knight
to d7 is better because it doesn't take
anything and okay then they you know
they did a little checks you never never
take anything and eventually they did
nothing for a long time and now i
blundered a seemingly normal move if you
just plays rook to h6 you know they just
keep playing tag and moving around and
shuffling and it probably end up being a
draw but wait played rook to e8
seems sensible enough but how does black
win now take the pawn with what okay I
guess that was easy for the crowd yeah
you just take and his his point was
apparently if you take here and assume
he was thinking that if you take this
way that I thought this maybe he thought
this was impossible because this would
be good for white but instead yeah he
just took the bishop and now white is it
a little bit of trouble so he gave a lot
of checks and the end also is very
pretty so it's it's worth seeing I mean
now white is up two ponds there's white
does have an exchange but just the
centralization and you know those ponds
are pretty aggressive here you could
again take um b2 but that's not how the
opening is played fine fine fine if it's
hanging for like 30 moves then then
maybe I'll take it so okay just here
I'm obviously could take on d1 as well
and train some stuff and win that way
that would have been the dani Machuca
recommended way the wind just trade all
the stuff and the finish position here
is actually phenomenal in this position
white resigned so for the exchange black
now is for ponds and what I really like
about this position is all of black
stuff is right in the middle it doesn't
get more centralized than that and white
stuff I mean this couldn't be farther
apart so for that reason he had had
enough it's it's quite a nice looking
position I think at the at the end there
so a very sharp stuff and this is only
day one there's a lot more entertaining
games to come so hopefully if you guys
enjoyed it you come back for part two
and three and until then please hit like
share subscribe and thanks everybody for
coming out